[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNA TAYLOR: So
today, we're super
excited to have a chef and
cookbook author, Brooke Lewy,
with us of the
"Vegetables on Fire"
cookbook, which truly could not
be more aligned with food team
values.
We are all about making
vegetables the most delicious
part of your meal.
And we really feel like a
predominantly plant-based diet,
not only best for you but for
the environment and the world
that we're all trying
to live in together.
We love meat.
We love really
high quality meat.
But vegetables, we think,
are truly the answer.
And in this season of
grilling, nothing better
than my personal favorite
food, grilled broccoli,
which there is an awesome
recipe in here for.
So with that, welcome.
BROOKE LEWY: Thank you.
Thank you guys so much for
having me and for coming.
It's really exciting to
see the book come to life
and get to cook from it
with people instead of just
developing recipes on my own.
And I was saying before,
grilling in San Francisco
is sometimes solitary, because
it's always really cold
JENNA TAYLOR: Out
on your fire escape.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
Exactly.
So it's really nice to
have a bunch of people
that cook with instead
of trying to convince
people to come outside with me.
So I don't know how-- how
many of you guys have grills,
do grill?
Just so I have an idea of
where you're coming from.
So, oh, great.
So a lot of people grill.
And the book also has tips
on how to make everything
at home if you don't inside.
So it kind of works either way.
So I think I'll get started.
The first--
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
What are we having today?
The first recipe that
we're going to demo
is a quinoa tabbouleh
stuffed pepper.
So we'll get started, and
then the second recipe
is going to be a
carrot and avocado
salad with all of the seeds.
With all of the seeds.
JENNA TAYLOR: All of them.
BROOKE LEWY: All of the seeds.
Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love it.
I read the title.
I'm like, you're
speaking my language.
BROOKE LEWY: So the
idea for this book
is basically that vegetables
are as delicious as meat
and that they can
be super satisfying.
So both of these
recipes really aim
to have a lot of
flavor and texture
and be really
satisfying on their own.
That said, I have ideas for
how you could incorporate meat
if you want, if you want to
make them more substantial.
So I'll kind of add that
in as we go through.
So for the pepper, I
just cut them in half.
You want to make them
like little bowls,
because you're then
going to stuff them.
So I take all the
ribs and seeds out.
We're going to add a
little bit of oil to them.
You can add olive or canola.
I use both in the book.
I kind of-- to keep
things simple-- just like
to use the same kind that I'm
using later in the recipe.
So like for this recipe
with the peppers,
I'm using olive oil
for the dressing.
So I just use olive
oil for the peppers,
so you don't have to have
too many things around.
Here, we happen to have both.
Another thing that
I talk about a lot
are the tools that I
like to use to grill.
And one of the things that I
like a lot are sheet trays.
I actually really like the
quarter sheet trays, which
are half the size of this.
They're awesome for
oiling vegetables
that don't fit well in a bowl.
We'll use them again
for the carrots.
It works great for
asparagus, anything
that's sort of unwieldy.
JENNA TAYLOR: So you
see those grill baskets,
but you're saying you
don't even need that.
Just put a regular
sheet pan on your grill.
BROOKE LEWY: You can use
these right on the grill,
but I even just mean for
prepping your vegetables.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, gotcha.
Yeah, well, this is the
best kitchen tool ever.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
And for bringing things
to and from the grill
so you don't have
a bunch of glass
bowls outside and
things that can break.
So I'm just rubbing oil on
the outside of the peppers.
I am going to sprinkle
with a little salt,
because you want everything
really well seasoned.
One thing that I
came across when
I started writing this
book is that people
who are generally really
creative, competent cooks kind
of shut down when they
start grilling vegetables.
And they just like default
to grilled zucchini or slices
of grilled eggplant, and
they're so boring and--
JENNA TAYLOR: Whomp-whomp.
BROOKE LEWY: --bland.
Yeah.
Grilled zucchini does
absolutely nothing for me.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
totally the worst.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
And you're like,
ugh, I guess somebody
decided to placate
the vegetarians here
at this barbecue.
JENNA TAYLOR: I was so relieved
that you said that, because it
could not be worse, really.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
So my whole mission
in this book is
to encourage
people, be creative,
use some of the things.
And even if you don't
make the whole recipe--
you'll see with
the carrot salad.
If you're like, I don't have
time to do this whole thing.
I'm not interested.
Even if you just add the
seeds to the carrots,
you have a dish that's
actually really delicious.
And--
JENNA TAYLOR: Even if you
just grill the carrots.
BROOKE LEWY: Even if you
JENNA TAYLOR: I
mean, I would argue
that'd still be delicious.
BROOKE LEWY: Exactly.
So while the peppers
are grilling,
I just put them cut side down.
I'm going to make the
tabbouleh for the-- that's
we're going to stuff them with.
So we have quinoa that your
lovely team here already
cooked for me.
We'll dump that in.
And we have some tomatoes.
We'll cut those up.
I'll move this till
we need it again.
So depending on-- you want
them on the smaller side,
because they're going
to go in the peppers.
So you want bite-sized.
So we'll just do a few.
With the cucumber, you
could peel it or not,
depending on your preference.
I'll peel a little.
You want it pretty small.
And all of the
recipes in this book
are meant to be flat-- flexible.
I think that's one of
the things about grilling
is every grill is
a little different.
Produce changes
depending on the year.
So it's nice to be
able to mix it up.
So this salad, you could
kind of do whatever.
This is a pretty
classic tabbouleh
with cucumber and tomato.
So we'll add some
cucumber in there.
If it has a lot of seeds, a good
trick is to cut it like this
and lay it on its side.
Can you guys see kind of?
And then just cut out
the seeds this way.
Sometimes, it's nice
to take those out
if there are a lot of them.
So I'll put those in the bowl.
Let's check out our
peppers real fast.
Tongs are an indispensable
grilling tool.
I don't like using
the ones that come--
they need a little
bit more time.
See?
They have some marks, but
they're not really soft yet.
The kind that come
with grill sets
are really stiff and
unwieldy, and they can often
hurt your delicate vegetables.
So this kind that's just
sturdy and normal kitchen tongs
are great.
The kind that comes tipped with
silicone are also really great.
Those are my favorite
grilling tools.
Let's keep adding
to our tabbouleh.
We'll add some olives.
If you don't like olives,
leave them out, obviously.
Chop--
AUDIENCE: Olive [INAUDIBLE]
BROOKE LEWY: Some people
don't like olives.
JENNA TAYLOR: Also
not my favorite.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, sorry.
JENNA TAYLOR: Confession.
Really black olives being the
worst offender of all of--
all of life.
AUDIENCE: More flavor
than [INAUDIBLE]
JENNA TAYLOR: These look lovely.
No offense.
BROOKE LEWY: [LAUGHS] And
then tabbouleh generally
has a lot of herbs, so we'll
put some green onion in there.
While I'm just
chopping up the stuff,
I can talk a little bit more.
You mentioned grill baskets.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
Tools that you
would recommend, or.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, so the
tongs, the quarter sheet trays
are two of my
absolute favorites.
In terms of grill
baskets, I don't really
like the very stiff ones.
They work.
They don't allow a lot
of that smoke flavor
to come up into the food.
They make mesh
disposable ones that you
can use a bunch of times,
and they're like $3.
You buy them at the hardware
store, and those work great.
And if you're trying to
grill something that's rolly,
like tomatoes, you
can turn up the sides,
so they don't roll off.
JENNA TAYLOR: That
sounds like a pro tip.
I'm going to look into that.
I haven't used those before.
BROOKE LEWY: They usually
come in packs of three.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh.
BROOKE LEWY: And
they're just like--
and also, you don't really
need to wash them as much.
Because that's the best
thing about grilling
is that there's much--
many fewer dishes, I would say.
I'm going to cut the parsley.
I usually bunch it up.
JENNA TAYLOR: What else
is indispensable to you?
BROOKE LEWY: The last
thing I would say
is heavy duty aluminum
foil is really useful.
If you don't have
a grill basket,
you can use that in a pinch.
It's really great
for making packets.
So if you make campfire-style
potatoes or you--
I have a recipe
for smoking beets,
where you smoke them
in a foil packet.
And it's actually one of my
favorite recipes in the book.
It's really good
and super simple.
OR also I do
artichokes that way.
And I feel like
artichokes are very often
cumbersome and annoying, and
people tend not to cook them.
Because it's like you
need the salt water
bath and-- or lemon water
bath, and steam them,
and they'll get hot.
But you can just put them
all in a foil packet,
put them on your
grill, they cook.
Eventually, you take
them out of the packet.
You throw them on the grill
itself, and then they're done.
And it's much less
of a production.
So those are really
my main cooking tools.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
what got you started
with the idea for
the book in general?
I mean, I love it, but--
BROOKE LEWY: To
be totally honest,
Chronicle came to
me with the idea.
They were really excited
about it and said,
would you want to do it?
Are you into it?
And I was.
JENNA TAYLOR: And you were
previously at Delfina--
BROOKE LEWY: Yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: --at the time?
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
So I worked the
grill station there.
There were some
veggies, mostly meat.
Yeah.
So--
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
such a fun project.
BROOKE LEWY: It
came about that way.
Yeah.
And it's been great.
And it definitely opened up
my eyes to grilling vegetables
and forced me to
be creative too.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, and
the glory of California,
you can grill year round.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right.
BROOKE LEWY: That's true.
JENNA TAYLOR: So it opens
up the possibilities.
And I know you mentioned--
she's from New York.
So probably not as
much grilling happening
in the winter in New York.
BROOKE LEWY: It's true.
So our peppers have gotten
soft halfway through,
which is what we're looking for.
You can see they're starting
to bend a little this way.
So I am going to--
in this recipe, I like
to put some cheese
in the cavity itself to
get a little bit melty.
And just make sure there's
cheese on both sides.
So I'm going to put
some cheese in there
and put it back on the grill.
And this is a really
good place to show
where you could put meat.
If you wanted to do some,
you could get some--
I would saute some onion
and some ground lamb
and saute it in a pan, put it
in the pepper under the cheese,
so it would get
warm-- stay warm.
And then you put your
tabbouleh on top.
And as you cut
through, then you get
tabbouleh and cheese and lamb.
And so it becomes
even more substantial
if you have a mixed
crew of people.
So we'll let those
cook on the other side.
Our table tabbouleh
is almost finished.
We need to make the dressing.
I really like to make
my dressing right
in measuring cups.
I feel like it saves dishes.
I don't know if you can tell,
I'm really into saving dishes.
JENNA TAYLOR: I am super
into your dish-less approach.
BROOKE LEWY: Nobody
likes to do dishes.
JENNA TAYLOR: No.
BROOKE LEWY: And especially
if you're hanging out outside,
the last thing you want to do
is go back in and be like, ugh,
I have so many dishes to wash.
JENNA TAYLOR: Look at
your mountain of dishes,
and you're really
want to hang out.
Yeah, I know.
I support that.
Yeah.
Right?
BROOKE LEWY: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
everyone else is outside,
and you're inside--
BROOKE LEWY: It's such a bummer.
JENNA TAYLOR: Looking
at your pile of stuff.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
So lemon juice-- this is
a really simple dressing.
It's nice to make the dressing
really bright, I would say.
Another thing about
grilled vegetables
is that they're often just
really sweet and soft.
And it's really important to
add enough salt and enough fat--
sorry, we're switching--
JENNA TAYLOR: An acid
BROOKE LEWY: Acid, yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: --to
get that brightness.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah exactly.
So all of these
recipes generally
have some kind of
fat or acid-- sorry.
Lemon juice, pinch
of salt, pepper.
Yeah, don't be afraid to
go big on the salting.
Little whisk making
some dressing.
[MIXING]
So we'll add this
to our tabbouleh.
We'll leave this
here, because we're
going to do another dressing
for our carrot salad.
Mix it all up.
And--
[MIXING]
--looks good.
Let's check back on our peppers.
They're looking pretty good too.
You just want them
cooked through
but to still have
some bite to them
and to hold their shape,
obviously, because you're
going to stuff them.
So we'll pull them off.
And add some tabbouleh.
The same thing that I was
saying with the seeds--
you don't have to go
through this whole thing
to make your grilled
vegetables delicious.
Even if you just make a peanut
sauce or a quick sauce and--
Green Goddess in a blender--
the book has an entire
section on little things
like that you can
do even in advance
that just makes such
a big difference
for your grilled veggies.
JENNA TAYLOR: But this
seemed also just quick, easy.
BROOKE LEWY: Well, it helps when
you guys do all the prep too.
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean, all
they did was cook the quinoa.
BROOKE LEWY: But it is really.
It's true.
It is really quick and easy.
And-- sorry.
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean,
theoretically you
could do like Trader Joe's
tabbouleh or something
and still your freshly
grilled pepper--
BROOKE LEWY: Totally.
Totally.
JENNA TAYLOR: And that
would be super delicious.
BROOKE LEWY: And then look
how much more appealing
this looks than just a plate
of grilled zucchini next to all
your burgers.
JENNA TAYLOR: Boo, zucchini.
BROOKE LEWY: So I don't
know where we should--
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
that's beautiful.
BROOKE LEWY: --put it.
Sorry, I don't want to give
grilled zucchini a bad rap.
JENNA TAYLOR: No, we should
just give it a bad rap.
It's terrible.
[LAUGHTER]
Prejudiced against zucchini.
Sorry.
BROOKE LEWY: But it's
like, your vegetarian
friends will be so much happy--
or not vegetarian friends.
Anybody--
JENNA TAYLOR: People who
like to eat veggies, yeah.
BROOKE LEWY: It's just--
JENNA TAYLOR: Well,
and I love the idea
of being able to have the same
dish that could be adapted
with meat if you really wanted
for people who especially
wanted that.
But I always disliked that
feeling of here's dinner,
and here's a vegetarian dish--
BROOKE LEWY: Totally.
JENNA TAYLOR: --for
my vegetarian friend.
BROOKE LEWY: Totally
it's really nice to--
JENNA TAYLOR: It's good
to have it really be--
BROOKE LEWY: --just
include everybody.
JENNA TAYLOR: --inclusive.
Yeah, right.
Like a menu that is
delicious for all eaters.
BROOKE LEWY: Totally.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love that.
BROOKE LEWY: So I'm going
to move this stuff away.
Maybe I can just
put it on this side.
Can I give this next to you?
So those are the
stuffed peppers.
Anybody have any
questions specifically
about stuffed peppers?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] substitute
any other tomatoes in here
if you don't have those ones.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, of course.
Just cut them little.
I mean, my mom said
to me a million times
when I was growing up
and helping her cook,
think about the size that you
want to put in your mouth,
which I hated her for saying.
But it's true.
You just don't want
to all fall out.
So for the carrots--
sorry.
Any other questions
about the peppers?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BROOKE LEWY: Not really.
It just adds a little
char to the outside.
And also, vegetables don't
flare up nearly as much
as meat does, because
there's no fat dripping off.
That's when you're
grilling, that's
where the flare ups come from.
And that's another
thing I would say
about cooking
vegetables in general
is that they're much
more forgiving than meat.
It's not like you just
paid $35 for ribeye,
and if you mess it
up, your dinner sucks.
And you just spent
a lot of money.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, it's like you can--
you-- we always want
to treat our food well,
but you can always throw
a few extra vegetables in
or learn as you're going.
And there's not
so much at stake.
It's a really good way to
get comfortable grilling,
to get to know your grill.
JENNA TAYLOR: Gas or charcoal?
Dun, dun, dun.
BROOKE LEWY: So I
think for vegetables
either one works
great, and gas is
the path of least resistance.
Because you just turn it on.
For me, I usually use charcoal.
You get a much better sear.
JENNA TAYLOR: Flavor.
BROOKE LEWY: I think
it's really hard
to get a good sear on meat,
burgers, whatever on a gas
grill.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JENNA TAYLOR: --the flavor of
charcoal too, that smokiness.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, it's
just a different thing.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm new to grilling.
What is a grill basket?
BROOKE LEWY: A grill basket?
JENNA TAYLOR: What
is a grill basket?
BROOKE LEWY: I think most
people use grill baskets
for vegetables and for fish.
There are kinds that just
sit on top of your grill.
And then there's
other ones, where
if you're making a whole fish,
you put the fish in there.
And you put it on,
and then you flip it.
That's usually it.
It's usually so
nothing falls down.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
You see them like perforated
metal baskets almost.
Like a lot of times if
I'm doing asparagus,
and you don't want it to
fall between the cracks
of the grill, put
it in a basket.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Can you
use a grill basket
for indoor cooking?
BROOKE LEWY: I don't think
you'd really need to, so.
JENNA TAYLOR: You
would use a regular pot
or pan or frying
pan or whatever.
It's like a frying pan for
your grill to some extent.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
Yeah.
If you're translating
the recipes to indoors,
either I'd use a grill pan if
you're grilling something like
lettuce-- if you're-- sorry.
If you're trying to do something
like a whole head of lettuce
or something, you could
use a grill pan for that.
Otherwise, I use
the broiler a lot.
But nothing's going to
fall through, you know.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
The basket, for me,
just generally keeps things
from falling through the spaces
in the grill.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, exactly.
So I'm going to move on to
the carrot and avocado salad.
And just keep asking
questions as we go.
These are really beautiful
carrots that you guys got.
They're pretty small.
I think I would cut them
in half just the long way.
One, like this, is really
tiny, so keep it as is.
This salad was inspired by
one that I ate in New York
at a restaurant called ABC
Kitchen that's also really veg
forward.
And it's just such a delicious
combination of things.
So a little olive oil.
See how easy this is to
do it on the grill pan
rather than fighting
with the shape of a bowl?
Salt, some pepper.
If your carrots
were really small--
for this recipe, I
also use pimenton,
which is like a
smoky paprika that I
use in a lot of the recipes.
It's kind of like a double
dose of that smoky flavor
by the time you put the
vegetables on the grill.
It works really nicely.
We'll just toss them
around a little.
This works great for
bringing things over,
especially if you're doing
the indoor/outdoor thing.
And I know most people
don't like mis-en-place
their stuff on trays,
like you guys do here,
but it actually works
really well for the grill.
I would say--
JENNA TAYLOR: Then you can
carry it all down to the grill.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And it doesn't
have to be a tray.
You could do it on a sheet pan.
BROOKE LEWY: Exactly.
It's really nice to
be super organized,
so you don't have to be running
in and out, and like, oh,
I forgot--
you know, I forget this thing.
I forgot the other thing,
especially if you're
grilling pizzas and
stuff, you want everything
to go pretty fast.
Everything does go pretty fast.
You want everything to
be pretty organized.
So while those are grilling,
I'm going to toast my seeds.
And when I toast seeds, I use
the path of least resistance.
So if I need to use a
pan for something later,
I'll use a pan.
I do it a lot in
the toaster oven,
just like whatever--
again, whatever
creates the fewest dishes.
JENNA TAYLOR: [LAUGHS]
I love that philosophy.
BROOKE LEWY: I'm going
to actually just put
this right on the grill.
I'm realizing now
that I'm at Google
that grilling vegetables is
like the most low-tech thing you
could possibly do.
And I feel like I'm in
this high-tech world, where
I'm like, and I'm
just gonna use fire.
JENNA TAYLOR: Food does
not have to be high-tech.
No, it's all about--
BROOKE LEWY: So I'm
going to let this-- maybe
I'll move my carrots over
a little to make room.
And I'm a big fan of doing
whatever you can on the grill
too, because part of
grilling is that you don't
have to get your house hot.
You don't have to
turn on the oven.
So there are a couple of
recipes in the book where you--
like fresh shakshuka.
You grill the vegetables.
You blend a bunch of them
up to make your sauce.
And then you just put the
pan right back on the grill.
So that works pretty well.
So this recipe uses sesame
seeds, pumpkin seeds,
and sunflower seeds,
and pistachios.
So I'm just going to--
JENNA TAYLOR: All of the seeds.
BROOKE LEWY: All of seeds.
JENNA TAYLOR: As you
said very clearly.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
So I'm actually going to
do my pistachios first.
Doesn't matter what
order you do them in.
Just toast them separately since
they toast at different rates.
Give them a shake.
We'll let those go.
JENNA TAYLOR: It
is in a dry pan?
BROOKE LEWY: Yes.
It is a dry pan.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
I feel like toasting nuts and
seeds is one of those kitchen
tests, where like,
don't walk away.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah,
no, it's true.
They burn so fast.
JENNA TAYLOR: So easily.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
And you just want to toast
them until they kind of smell
all nutty and golden and
have some color on them.
So they'll go.
And if you have people
who are allergic to nuts,
just leave them out.
If you didn't want
to do nuts and seeds,
or if you didn't want to
buy all the different seeds,
you could buy one and just
have the volume be the same.
Or you could use breadcrumbs.
You could do-- pretty
flexible things.
[SNIFFING]
These are not-- they're going
to take a little while, I think.
Some of the other
things I discovered
while writing this
book is that you
can use a lot of
the techniques you
use with meats, like marinating
or pre-salting on vegetables
too.
It works really well.
So with something
like cabbage that's
so dense, if you salt it ahead
of time, like a few hours,
it really draws out the flavor.
Same thing, I have a recipe
in there for a squash curry,
where I marinate the squash
in the curry sauce, I guess.
And it really just gets
the flavor in there.
So there are lots of ways to
be creative with vegetables.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
that's a great point.
I think people don't
always think about that.
Like marinating a vegetable
could have the same effect,
or using the same
spice, like rubs,
that you might use
on a piece of meat.
You could rub a head of
cauliflower or a cauliflower
steak and get a
similar taste profile.
That's a pro tip
everybody talks about.
I think there's a
whole generation that
did vegetables steamed.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Many
of our parents
or grandparents kind
of default to that.
And I just think that
there's so much you could do
in terms of vegetable cookery.
BROOKE LEWY: It's true.
JENNA TAYLOR: Treat them like
ingredients on their own.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, exactly.
So these carrots
are almost good.
They're getting really
nice char marks.
They're getting softer.
You don't want them
to be too hard.
I think our pistachios
are toasted.
They're starting to
smell extra pistachioy.
We'll put them back
in their little bowl.
I'll do the
sunflower seeds next.
We'll get those on the grill.
I'm gonna pull the carrots off.
You could plate this up on
a really nice, big platter,
and it looks very beautiful.
We'll just do an
individual portion.
And this kind of salad you
don't toss all together.
You layer it.
So you'll see as we build it.
Give our sunflower seeds a toss.
We'll put these in the bowl too.
And we'll do our pumpkin seeds.
And let those heat up.
JENNA TAYLOR: So what are
your layers going to be?
BROOKE LEWY: We'll do
the layer of the carrots.
And then-- oh, shoot.
I forgot to grill my citrus.
Sorry.
So grilled citrus is another
really good chefy thing.
Once you have your
grill on anyway,
you might as well have
some grilled citrus,
because even if you don't
do anything with it--
which we will.
We're going to
make the dressing.
It looks really
pretty on the plate.
It looks impressive.
So let's add those.
I'm doing exactly
what you shouldn't do
and walking away from my seeds.
So hopefully they won't burn.
JENNA TAYLOR: We
put that juju out.
I don't know.
It might now.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
Let's add our citrus on here.
right.
So we'll do the carrots.
We'll do avocado, some arugula,
and then all the seeds.
JENNA TAYLOR: So this
would be a great one,
like you said, to do
one big family style.
BROOKE LEWY: Totally.
JENNA TAYLOR: Platter,
barbecuing, or summer picnic.
BROOKE LEWY: And it's
good at room temperature.
I would say a lot of the
time grilled vegetables are
kind of best right when they
come off, I think, the grill.
Room temperature vegetables are
leftover and not that great,
but this one is really
good at room temperature.
So we'll wait for our
sesame seeds to toast.
The citrus doesn't
take very long.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
are you looking for?
Just some marks on it?
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah,
and it kind of gets
soft and a little caramelized.
So as soon as these get
there, I'll show them to you.
The sesame seeds
are taking on color.
They go faster than anything.
Now they're kind of nutty
smelling, a little more golden
brown.
They'll continue
cooking from the heat
of the pan a little bit, so you
can pull them a little early.
That's a good tip, because they
can get burned really fast.
So we have our seeds.
We'll add a big pinch of
salt, mix them up a little.
While our citrus is grilling,
we can get our avocado ready.
I think everybody knows
how to cut avocados, right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Carefully?
BROOKE LEWY: In
California-- yeah.
Pry it open.
And get that out of there.
So I have to say, since
this is my first cookbook,
I realized a thing.
That as somebody who
usually only cooks
the recipes that
have pictures, I
beg you to look at the recipes
that don't have pictures.
Because they're some
of the best ones.
So I can add this avocado.
JENNA TAYLOR: How do you make
that decision as the cookbook
author?
Do you get to say like--
BROOKE LEWY: I wish
it was my decision.
JENNA TAYLOR: --these are
the glamour shots I want.
BROOKE LEWY: No.
JENNA TAYLOR: Highlight
these, publisher.
BROOKE LEWY: Maybe if you're
like Ina Garten, you do.
[LAUGHTER]
But if you're me,
they're like, we
want to shoot these 20 recipes.
What do you think?
JENNA TAYLOR: And you
have to say, sure thing!
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, basically.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
BROOKE LEWY: I was like,
no, you should really
shoot these other ones.
And you know.
JENNA TAYLOR: But those
are the good sleeper
hits that, you
know, B-side tracks
people will come to love.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah,
and I would say
that a lot of the
time people ask me
what my favorite
recipes are in the book,
and I really loved
the ones where
I had to learn as I was going.
So like the smoked beets,
for example, or the squash
curry is really cool.
The artichokes I've really--
that's a great technique.
So this orange is
starting to get there.
See?
It's nice and caramelized
There's brown spots.
It's getting softer.
So we can take this guy off.
The lemons need- and this
lemon is pretty good too.
So let's put these over here.
And in trying to stress the
ease of grilling vegetables,
even if you took that
lemon and squeezed it
over your plate of
grilled zucchini,
it would be better than
if you just left it plain.
So for this dressing, you
let these cool a little bit.
You can see we're
building our salad.
Again, dressing in
the measuring cup.
Give it a squeeze.
When you grill the lemon--
grill citrus, you also--
it gives up a lot more juice
than it would otherwise.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, I was
going to say, that thing.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's impressive.
BROOKE LEWY: And
it makes the citrus
a little bit less acidic, a
little sweeter and more mellow,
which is nice.
This recipe makes more
dressing than you need,
but it's nice to
use on other salads.
So we'll squeeze
all that in there.
Maybe we'll leave this one on
the plate to be very pretty.
JENNA TAYLOR:
"Chefy," as you said.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, exactly.
This one, add some vinegar.
This is apple cider vinegar
to add a little more acidity,
since the citrus does
get really sweet.
Some salt-- probably
want to do a big pinch.
Pepper.
Whisk it up.
[MIXING]
It's nice to add a little bit
to dress your greens first.
So usually with greens--
I don't know if you guys know.
The best way to dress a
salad is to salt it first
before you add any
of the dressing.
So the salt gets
evenly dispersed,
so it doesn't clump on the
pieces that are the wettest.
That's good.
JENNA TAYLOR:
That's a great tip.
I hadn't heard that one before.
BROOKE LEWY: Oh, yeah.
It's a good way to go.
That was one of the first
things I learned to Delfina.
So you want to dress your
greens, so they're all dressed.
Your hands work great.
Tongs kind of bruise lettuces.
So we'll add the
arugula around--
sorry.
Pull some of your avocado
and your carrots on top,
so it's all mixed together.
Add a little more dressing.
Drizzle it over the top.
And then, sprinkle
on all your seeds.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's beautiful.
It smells amazing from
where I'm standing.
I don't know if you guys
are getting it but, whoof.
BROOKE LEWY: So you
can see all the layers.
It does look really
beautiful on a big platter.
And in each bite, you
get the kind of sweet,
smoky from the carrot, and
the cool avocado, and all
the crunchy seeds, and
the citrusy dressing.
And it's just at really
nice, balanced salad.
JENNA TAYLOR: Beautiful.
Thank you so much.
BROOKE LEWY: Thank
you guys so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you
guys have questions?
Yeah.
Is there a particular
marinade you
recommend that's
especially good with veg?
BROOKE LEWY: Sure.
I think they mostly all work.
I mean, my favorite
marinades are
like the lemon, olive oil,
whatever herbs you have,
works great.
A chimichurri sauce
works great, because you
can use it before and after.
Or like a soy, sesame oil,
brown sugar kind of marinade
also works really well if I
want to go in a more like Asiany
direction.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
You had a question over here?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
[INAUDIBLE]
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, cool question.
So where do you get
your inspiration,
and how do you as
the cook really
like learn in the process
of creating recipes?
BROOKE LEWY: I spent a lot of
time online googling things.
I read a lot of cookbooks
and a lot of food web sites.
And I feel like there's
inspiration everywhere.
Or like the carrot
salad, if I go out to eat
and I really like
something that I eat,
kind of trying to figure out
how to recreate it at home
and then learning how to do it.
It's just a lot
of trial and error
and cross-referencing
a lot of recipes
and trying out like, oh, this
technique for smoking potatoes
works really well.
I wonder if it'll
work for beets too.
They have a similar texture.
JENNA TAYLOR: Who's your
favorite food blogger or food
website?
What's your go-to?
BROOKE LEWY: So I have
two little kids right now.
So a lot of my cooking
is really simple.
A lot of Smitten
Kitchen recipes--
they always come out
really, really well.
They're pretty easy.
She also has a--
little kids.
So she feels the insanity.
JENNA TAYLOR: Many
of us do, surely.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What do you to get
your kids to eat vegetables?
JENNA TAYLOR: What
do you do to get
your kids to eat vegetables?
Please, please tell me.
BROOKE LEWY: I think that
they don't know what they're
supposed to like and not like.
So I think if you--
I've gone so far as to tell
my son roasted brussel sprouts
are like brussel sprout french
fries, which he kind of-- he
ate one.
I don't know.
JENNA TAYLOR: He's
like, I don't know.
All right.
She's trying.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
But I mean, they don't
know what they're
supposed to like and not like.
So if you're like, here, try it.
It's delicious.
Then, they're like, OK.
And they might like it.
They might not like it, but
as long as you treat it all
like it's all just
food, you know,
that seems to kind
of work for me.
JENNA TAYLOR: Don't
pre-prejudice them.
BROOKE LEWY: It seems to
kind have worked for me.
JENNA TAYLOR:
That's a cool idea.
I like that.
BROOKE LEWY: Or my
mother-in-law is always
like, I can't believe you're
giving him kale or whatever.
I'm like, he doesn't--
my son doesn't really eat kale.
But I've made him try it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JENNA TAYLOR: Kale.
BROOKE LEWY: He doesn't know.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, it's normal.
BROOKE LEWY: I don't know.
JENNA TAYLOR: He doesn't
know it's trendy.
BROOKE LEWY: If you assume
he's not going to like it
and don't offer it, they're
never going to like it, so.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
a great approach.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ooh, what
about grilling avocado?
BROOKE LEWY: I have for this
salad, and it totally works.
It's just whether you want
more of that the temperature
contrast or more grill flavor.
But that's the great thing
about grilling, right?
You can do-- or
cooking in general--
you can just do a few--
JENNA TAYLOR:
Totally [INAUDIBLE]..
BROOKE LEWY: Grill your avocado.
Yeah.
And I really--
JENNA TAYLOR: Sounds yummy.
BROOKE LEWY: Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
And a lot of these recipes in
this book are pretty flexible.
I give specified amounts
of oil, but really it's
like, use enough oil to
cook your vegetables.
Your grill might be
hotter than my grill.
And things might take longer.
Who knows?
JENNA TAYLOR: Trust yourself.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BROOKE LEWY: How
hot the grill is?
JENNA TAYLOR: OK, so question.
Do you grill veg at
the same temps as meat,
and do you have
methodology for monitoring
your grill temperature?
BROOKE LEWY: There's not
a great way to monitor.
I mean, lots of people say the
hand test, which I have in--
I put in the book and then
was reading more about it
and was like, oh,
yeah, of course.
Everybody has different
pain thresholds.
So that's probably
not the best way,
even though I wrote it in there.
Vegetables, generally,
are at medium.
They don't need to be as hot.
I feel like meats
you cook hotter,
because you really
want that sear.
And vegetables you need to
be a little more gentle.
I would say, again,
test a piece and see
if it seems like
the right amount
or if you want to wait for
the grill to cool down more.
One thing I would say
that a lot of people
probably don't realize
is for charcoal grills,
you want to cook with
the top open mostly.
And with gas grills, you want
to cook with the top closed
to keep the heat in.
I think a lot of
people get their grill,
don't read about how
you're supposed to do it,
and just cook with it open.
And people will stand
there at their gas grill
like, why the hell
isn't anything cooking?
And that's why.
You have to cook with the top
closed as much as you can.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And why
would you do that?
BROOKE LEWY: To allow
more air to circulate.
So the way the heat goes is
different between the two.
Yeah.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's delicious.
BROOKE LEWY: Oh, thanks.
JENNA TAYLOR: Survey
says, super yummy.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: And the
carrot dish is vegan.
The peppers are vegetarian.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
BROOKE LEWY: Cooking mushrooms?
JENNA TAYLOR: What
types of mushrooms
are best on the grill?
BROOKE LEWY: They're all
really good, honestly.
I would definitely
use a grill basket.
Mushrooms are hard
to get to stay.
I know portobellos are classic
as the veggie alternative.
I also think they're
kind of bland.
Sorry.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Marinated-- that's where
I've applied marinating veggie.
BROOKE LEWY: It's true.
JENNA TAYLOR: Like a marinated
portobello can be good,
but on their own, I mean, yeah.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Especially
if you are presenting it
as a hamburger alternative.
So your vegetarian friend, like,
do something to it, please.
BROOKE LEWY: But in
the book, there's
a recipe for mixed
vegetable spring rolls.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yum.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah,
that are really good.
And you just use any
type of mushroom.
For mushrooms, you
can use higher heat.
And it releases that water.
And just season
them really well.
And really, any kind
is very delicious.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
grilling indoors--
how do you decide what you do?
BROOKE LEWY: It kind of depends
on what kind of vegetable
it is.
So if you're just looking
for that sear on the outside,
I would use a grill pan.
If you're looking to cook
the vegetable through,
like the carrot--
or the peppers,
actually, I would
either roast it at a high
heat or use the broiler.
And every recipe in the
book has the suggestion
for how I would--
how I would--
JENNA TAYLOR: Perfect.
Perfect.
BROOKE LEWY: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Excellent.
Well, I thank you so much.
BROOKE LEWY: Thank you
so much for having me.
JENNA TAYLOR: It was
so fun, and I love it.
Right now, I can't wait to
go to the farmer's market
this weekend and get a bunch
of stuff and grill it all up.
So thank you, and
hopefully, you'll
come back and see us again.
BROOKE LEWY: I would love that.
Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: They're all
eating, but I'll [INAUDIBLE]..
BROOKE LEWY: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]